this is one that I just really want to
put out there an overview on the
language of filmmaking focusing on the
basic cuts this is going to be a very
broad overview of the basics of the
subject primarily aimed at people who
are new if you're already familiar with
language of editing's and this may be
mostly repetition of stuff you already
know but I hope I've managed to present
the information in a way that's
entertaining and maybe makes you take a
second look at the way that you think
about what you already know the first
thing that needs to be mentally sorted
is that there are two broad categories
of cuts that we're going to talk about
or put another way there are two
different contexts where we'll talk
about the type of cut used the first is
mechanical what physically is the editor
doing to assemble the footage
the second is narrative what is the
outcome of the cut in terms of story and
meaning it's important to be aware of
the two different contexts because it
helps keep in mind that a cut is often
more than just one thing usually having
at least two components its physical
form and its narrative function so first
the mechanical cuts right off the top
the single most common type of cut the
straight cut one clip ends another
begins this is the default cut this is
what you'll get when you take two
different shots and join them together a
straight cut next the split edit now
these days this applies more cleanly to
documentary corporate video and
commercials simply because of the way
that narrative features are assembled
the split edit comes in two flavors the
L cut and the J cut the whole idea here
is that the audio associated with a clip
either leaves or trails to cut when the
audio leads the cut it's a J cut and
when the audio trails it's an L cut the
reason for the naming is visual in the
editing suite the cuts end up looking
like this l and J now in a narrative
feature this gets muddled for moments
moment the editing in
film can get quite complicated
particularly because of the soundtrack
is typically woven together from dozens
of different sources take for example
this dialogue in 10 Cloverfield Lane
where the sound and picture weaves back
and forth between the two characters
just leave and this act means fall out
which contaminates the air above ground
that's that's our works how long do we
have to wait until it's safe it goes on
approximately the closest place when
we're moving to 10 Cloverfield Lane is a
very good movie and it's editing is
excellent because of this complexity the
place that a split edit is going to be
most clear is over a scene transition
where audio from a different time and
place leads or trails the cut this might
be substantial such as this moment in
Man of Steel where the incoming audio
leads the cut by several seconds I just
want to do something useful with my life
or it might be quite subtle like the
sound of this door closing trailing the
cut by a matter of frames retained even
and opposition your capacity for Stosh
next up is the jump cut this one you're
probably intensely familiar with as it
has been used some would say to excess
on YouTube this is when a clip cuts into
itself
now there's another use of this phrase
as a pejorative and that's when a clip
cuts into a second clip that isn't
properly differentiated from the first
clip like they may technically be two
different shots but they're too similar
making the cut between them feel awkward
and wrong the last of the mechanical
cuts is the transition a transition cut
is any kind of mixing effects that
merges two clips together whether it be
a fade a dissolve or any of the many
many many white for transit effects
including but not limited to linear
horizontal push horizontal linear
vertical push vertical barndoors iris
cross white star white heart
white diamond white radial wipe card
white venetian blind twister jaws cube
spin flip over page peel page turn and
cross zoom moving on we get into the
narrative cuts describing a cut in terms
of its intent or content this is also
where things start to get really funky
because any given cut may function as
one or more of these for example let's
start with the match cut the basic idea
of a match cut is that some visual
element is present to make physically
discontinuous action appear continuous
the hand starts to raise in the a shot
and the action is completed in the B
shot this idea expands into the graphic
match cut where some visual element on
each side of the cut links the two
together such as this the best edit in
all of the lost world Jurassic Park
[Music]
in this case in addition to the visual
match of the mouse the audio of the
screen is also blended with the sound of
the train so this is a match both
visually and on the soundtrack this
specific cut is also an example of a
contrast cut the mother's terror is
juxtaposed with Malcolm's boredom to
create humor if least I think that's
what they were going for it's it's a
very strange edit the contrast cut can
also be used with the intent of drawing
a connection between two things to imply
that they are an extension of one
another or to create commentary cutting
from a crowd of Christmas shoppers to a
herd of sheep being the archetypal
example hey hey Dan do you know about
that one shot they do that in 2001 you
know that shot with the bone and the
bone becomes a missile platform you know
about that shot right yeah I know about
that shot okay just checking the next
thing we're going to discuss is the
cross cut now cross cutting also called
parallel cutting isn't quite accurate as
a singular cut but is rather a
description of a series of cuts the way
of structuring a scene where two
displaced actions are cut together the
implication being that they are
happening simultaneously or near
simultaneously this is fairly standard
for action scenes where there may not be
anything other than general implication
or location to tie shots to each other
such as in the bike chase in a key row
where we cut between various aspects of
the chase without strict continuity of
action
[Music]
[Applause]
in the film in Bruges it's used to
connect three simultaneous events Ken
crawling to the window of the bell tower
Harry descending the bell tower and ray
at the cafe with Chloe three events
three locations intercut to keep the
audience oriented to things that are
happening simultaneously the last type
of edit that we're going to talk about
is a bit of a special consideration so
it describes a kind of shot as much as
it describes the kind of Edit and that's
the insert an insert is a cut from the
main action to a detail of interest
either to the material of the story or
to the somatic fabric a common example
of an insert is basically any time a
character is doing something with their
hands in documentaries inserts are used
frequently to simply add interest and
rhythm to illustrate a point or to
facilitate pacing from enron the
smartest guys in the room we have all of
these shots of documents being shredded
well the narrator talks about Enron
shredding documents but the important
thing to keep in mind is that this is
not actually footage of Enron documents
being shredded this is not literally
what they're talking about it's just
symbolic of what they're talking about
so there you go a broad overview of the
basic lexicon of editing here's a kitty
[Music]
you
[Music]